[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend sich selbst zu
begegnen das ist Olaf Scholz in Indien
wieder fahren bevor er Premierminister
Modi getroffen hat die Straßen waren
zugepflastert mit seinem konterfrei eine
Schmeichelei von Seiten des Gastgebers
die es im Grunde aber gar nicht
gebraucht hätte denn Scholz ist auf
werbereise er braucht den globalen Süden
um eine Neuausrichtung der Außenpolitik
zu vollziehen es ist aber nicht nur oder
unbedingt Überzeugung sondern
insbesondere die Not die den
Bundeskanzler antreibt der Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine hat die
Abhängigkeiten Deutschlands ungeschönt
offengelegt Scholz will daher die eigene
Abhängigkeit von China verringern und
Indiens enge Bindung zu Russland
Schwächen im alltempo enorm unter
berichtet
crickets ist ein kompliziertes Spiel
allein die grobe Einweisung ins
Regelwerk hätte wohl zwei Wochen
verlangt oder mehr zwei Tage nur war der
Kanzlei in Indien die Konzentration aufs
wesentlicher ein Motto das diese Reise
ganz gut umschreibt das Team sei das
Bayern München des Cricket lernt Scholz
der Hamburger und trägt sie alles mit
Fassung was hilft weil Indien nun mal
kein leichter Partner ist vor allem
jetzt
westliche Nationen verzweifeln
regelmäßig an Indien weil es sich
weigert gegen Russland Position zu
beziehen aber es erscheint unmöglich das
zu verurteilen weil Indien gebraucht
wird auch um China in den Schranken zu
halten die Weltordnung ist gerade sehr
kompliziert und Modi versucht das Beste
für sich herauszuholen
Olaf Scholz scheint das zu akzeptieren
immer wieder betont er die Freundschaft
zwischen ihm und dem Kollegen Modi
zwischen Indien und Deutschland
[Musik]
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass unsere
Länder eng verbunden sind weil wir
ähnliche Vorstellungen haben ganz
besonders was die Demokratie betrifft
und die Bedeutung die die für unser
Leben und für die Zukunft hat Indien ist
die größte Demokratie der Welt heißt des
was stimmt wenn es um die
Bevölkerungsgröße geht aber die 1,4
Milliarden leben in einem System mit
Schwächen systematisch hat die
Regierungspartei Institutionen mit
Getreuen besetzt und Gegner entfernt
die Demokratie wurde in großem Maße
ausgehöhlt seit Modi regiert seit 2014
ich kann nicht erkennen dass
ausgerechnet die Regierung Modi
entschlossen wäre sich für eine starke
demokratische Praxis in der Politik
einzusetzen
Modis BJP steht für Hindu-Nationalismus
es herrscht er glaube dass Indien das
Land der Hindus sei dieser Glaube
herrscht im Wortsinn andere Religionen
Muslime vor allem spüren Diskriminierung
auch die Pressefreiheit hat einen
schweren Stand jüngster die BBC gewagt
kritisch über Modi zu berichten kurz
darauf standen die Finanzbehörden vor
der Tür durchsuchten die Büros der
Vorwurf Steuerhinterziehung die
Ausstrahlung des Films in Indien wurde
verboten
nein Indien ist kein einfacher Partner
eher ein sensibler der Kanzler setzt da
lieber auf verbindendes in punkto
Wirtschaft ist das nicht schwer an das
wo schon und wer die Symbolik dazu sucht
der konnte sie finden als der Zauber
Indiens auf hansiatische Nüchternheit
stieß
bei dieser Reise ging es nun mal darum
aus unterschiedlichen Welten gemeinsame
Interessen herauszufiltern
und über die Neuausrichtung Deutschlands
möchte ich jetzt mit Navid Kermani
sprechen der Schriftsteller beobachtet
seit Jahrzehnten das politische
Weltgeschehen fährt immer wieder in
kriegs- und Krisengebiete so auch in die
Ukraine um sich dann in politische
Debatten einzumischen und so hat er vor
Monaten der deutschen Politik
jahrzehntelanges Zitat dramatisches
Versagen im Hinblick auf die
Abhängigkeit mit Russland vorgeworfen
und damit einen schönen guten Abend nach
Köln
guten Abend er kann meine Olaf Scholz
sagt über Indien wer hätten ähnliche
Vorstellungen insbesondere was die
Demokratie betrifft sie kennen Indien
gut folgt auf einen dramatisches
Versagen jetzt eine dramatische
Fehleinschätzung
also wir sind nicht in einer
vergleichbaren Abhängigkeit von Indien
die Beziehungen sind andere aber die
fehlereinschätzung ist schon sehr
ähnlich und es war ein Bericht ja auch
schon die Rede von dem
Menschenrechtsverletzung die übrigens
unter anderem auch von Deutschland im
Unmenschen Menschen
Menschenrechtsrat angeprangert werden
speziell Mode ist verwickelt in das
Massaker von 2002 wo ungefähr 2000
Menschen starben betätigt einen strengen
Internationalismus hat sehr konservative
extrem konservative Werte im Vergleich
zu ihm ist jemand wie orbanien liberale
man kann mit Indien reden man sollte
auch in den Reden aber man muss ihn
nicht zum Gleichgesinnten ernennen das
wird ein sehr schlechtes Licht auf
unsere eigene Gesinnung
Scholz hält in den ja auch für einen
Schlüssel Land bei der Neuordnung der
Welt und diese Neuordnung ist ja eine
Konsequenz aus dem Angriffskrieg
Russlands china hat ein Positionspapier
zur politischen Lösung vorgelegt 12
Punkte in den Russland weder als
Aggressor benannt noch zum Rückzug
aufgefordert wird fast alle westlichen
Länder haben dieses Papier im Grunde
weggewischt und ich China als pseudo
Friedenstifter hingestellt ein Fehler
ich würde das nicht sofort wegwischen
diese dieses Positionspapier das ist
schon insofern bemerkenswert als China
gerade weil es ein Verbündeter Russlands
ist sich dennoch zur territorialen
Souveränität Integrität der Ukraine
bekannt hat das ist ein neuer Schritt
das unterscheidet sich von der
russischen Position bekanntlich und das
sollte man das Aufgreifen man sollte
jedes Chance für einen Frieden nutzen
ausloten zumindestens aber um auch das
zu sagen also dieses Positionspapier
kommt jetzt ein Jahr nach Ausbruch des
Krieges weil die Ukraine sich gewehrt
hat hätte die Ukraine kapituliert hätten
wir können nicht unterstützt dann werde
ich ihn ja sicherlich nicht zu dieser
Position gekommen die ja ein Zeichen
auch der Schwäche von Russland ist also
offenbar wird hier nach Lösung gesucht
und wir müssen uns immer klar machen wir
unterstützen der besten unterstützt die
Ukraine zurecht die verteidigt sich die
Ukraine aber um zu und wofür
unterstützen wir Sie um irgendwann eine
Verhandlungslösung zu erreichen um die
Ukraine in den Stand zu setzen überhaupt
Verhandlung führen zu können und wenn
wir uns dem jetzt näheren sollten dann
wäre das zumindest ein Fortschritt sie
hatten gerade territoriale Integrität
gesagt das stimmt da steht in dem Papier
China sagt aber auch man solle die
legitim Sicherheitsinteressen aller
Länder ernst nehmen und gemeint sind
damit natürlich russlandsinteressen und
das ist wiederum natürlich auch eine
Rechtfertigung für den Krieg selensky
der ukrainische Präsident sieht jetzt in
Bezug auf das Papier offensichtlich das
schon auch eine Chance immerhin schlägt
er jetzt einen china-gipfel vor was muss
denn eigentlich das Kriegsziel des
Westens sein wenn schon mit politischen
Grundsätzen und Grundfesten ja gebrochen
wurde nämlich Waffen in ein Kriegsgebiet
zu liefern
also eigentlich das ursprüngliche
Kriegsziel das scheint mir ein bisschen
aus den Augen zu beraten ich sehe da so
ein bisschen die Gefahr dass wir in so
ein Autopilot geraten und vergessen
warum wir eigentlich die Waffen liefern
nämlich nicht um Russland zu besiegen
das war nicht das ursprüngliche Ziel
sondern um die Ukraine zu verteidigen
damit sie ihr Territorium verteidigen
kann dem die Menschen dort leben können
so wie Sie möchten und auf dieses Ziel
sollten wir uns konzentrieren und dieses
Ziel ist uns zuletzt vielleicht ein
bisschen aus nicht mehr so deutlich
benannt und ganz schlimm wäre das Video
Ukraine wenn es darauf hinauslaufen
würde dass es ein Jahr Jahre langer
vielleicht sogar
jahrzehntelangestellungskrieg ist
insofern sollten wir die Ukraine
unterstützen wir sollten auch Waffen
liefern diejenigen die Waffen die
notwendig sind welche das sind das kann
ich schlecht beurteilen das können
andere besser aber damit sie dann
irgendwann auch hoffentlich in eine
starke Verhandlungsposition Gerät
starke Verhandlungsposition ist wichtig
wirtschaftliche Interessen spielen
natürlich auch immer wieder eine Rolle
vor allen Dingen und das ist der zweite
Themenkomplex mit denen über den ich
gleich mit ihnen sprechen möchte und
zwar blicken wir gleich auf den Iran und
wenn wir auf den Iran schauen und das
werden sie liebe Zuschauer und
Zuschauerinnen ja mitbekommen haben seit
Monaten gehen dort Menschen auf die
Straße um für Freiheit und auch für
Menschenrechte zu demonstrieren das
Regime antwortet mit massiver Gewalt von
systematischer Folter bis hin zu
ausgeführten Todesstrafen und dennoch
geht die Revolution weiter geht
allerdings auch der Bau der Atombombe
der Iran soll bei fast 90% Anreicherung
angekommen sein und zudem soll Teheran
Marschflugkörper mit großer Reichweite
entwickelt haben Kamera safariieren
stolz präsentiert Iran seinen neuesten
Marschflugkörper VW Iran rüstet sein
Raketen und Atomprogramm weiter auf ein
Kommandeur droht im Fernsehen obendrein
noch mit der Tötung von Ex-US-Präsident
Trump fragt man die Menschen auf dem
Basar von Norden Teherans nach ihren
Problemen hört man ganz andere Töne
alles wird teurer und schlimmer und die
Verantwortlichen kümmern sich nicht um
uns
an die politischen Gefangenen und was
sie durchmachen die Jugendlichen die
Hingerichteten ich könnte heulen
trotzdem demonstrieren die Menschen
immer wieder die hier in Sorge Dorn oder
heute in Teheran was die Welt nicht
sieht was mit den über 20.000
verhafteten in den Haftanstalten und
Folterkellern des Regimes passiert
der US-Nachrichtensender CNN hat jetzt
Folteropfer ausfindig gemacht
die ist Medizinstudent und wollte
verletzten Demonstranten helfen dann
wird er verhaftet
sie wollten mich zerstören der Folterer
nahm einen Schlagstock und stellte sich
hinter mich ich dachte er will mich
zusammenschlagen dann aber hat er mich
mit seinem Schlagstock vergewaltigt
nach CNN Recherchen soll es über drei
Dutzend foltereinrichtungen in Iran
geben neben Gefängnissen auch Schulen
Verwaltungsgebäude und Militärbasen
Menschenrechtsorganisationen bestätigen
das wir erfahren von allen Arten von
foltern und auch allen aus allen
möglichen Gebäuden oder Einrichtungen
also physische Folter wie dass man die
Menschen boxt auspeitscht dass man sie
mit Schläuchen oder Kabeln schlägt mit
Elektroschocks Mal trittiert
vergewaltigt
oder dass man sie in der Kälte frieren
lässt und sie zwingt sich nackt zu
machen oder mit nassen Tüchern bei einer
erstickt auch der Arzt muss
im Krankenhaus versorgen und wurde dafür
gefoltert
respektieren keinerlei Menschenrechte
keiner kontrolliert was sie tun auch
nicht die Vergewaltigung
die Folteropfer leben inzwischen an
einem unbekannten Ort außerhalb Irans
für viele andere gehen die Qualen weiter
und diese Woche wurde nun ein
deutsch-irana zu Tode verurteilt zum
Tode wir haben hier darüber berichtet
die Konsequenz die Bundesregierung hat
zwei iranische Diplomaten zu
unerwünschten Personen erklärt darüber
möchte ich jetzt weiter mit dem
Schriftsteller Navid Kermani sprechen da
kann man die vor Monaten haben sie ja
hier schon im heute journal der
Bundesregierung vorgeworfen nichts zu
tun
reicht das alles was sie jetzt sehen was
Deutschland tut
also die deutsche Position hat sich
schon geändert also das Interview dass
wir damals geführt haben das war sechs
Wochen nach Beginn der Proteste es gab
keine einzige substanzielle Äußerung des
Bundeskanzlers inzwischen gibt es gute
Äußerungen der Ton hat sich geändert in
der Sache hat sich aber noch bei weitem
nicht genug getan also zwei Diplomaten
auszuweisen das ist bei einem
Todesurteil gegen einen deutschen
Staatsbürger doch ungefähr das was man
am äußersten untersten Rand überhaupt
tun könnte um darauf zu reagieren welche
Erwartung haben Sie denn an die
Bundesregierung wie sollte sie denn
reagieren welche Möglichkeiten gibt es
denn
also zum einen ist es ja das konkrete
Anliegen vieler Iraner und auch andere
Staaten wie es andere Staaten ja auch
gemacht haben die revolutionsgarten die
maßgeblich für die niederschlagen und
die Folter und und die Unterdrückung der
Bevölkerung verantwortlich sind auf die
Terrorliste zu setzen auch weil sie im
Nahen Osten anderswo für viel ungutes
sorgen für Terror sorgen vor allem aber
sollte sich Deutschland einsetzen dafür
auch bei anderen Ländern dass die Welt
begreift dass dieses Regime keine
Zukunft hat das ist das ist eine Zukunft
verspielt hat dass die Menschen diese
Regime ablehnen und das kann ich
Stabilität herzustellen ist mit diesem
Regime also all das was sich deutsche
Realpolitik vorgestellt hat etwa auch
dass man an die Gas kommen abgegas
vorkommen kommt regionale Stabilität man
sieht es ja auch in der Ukraine jetzt
wieder also das ist mit diesem Regime
nicht herzustellen das hat seine
Bevölkerung verloren und dann sollte
sich einstellen auf einen langen Kampf
das ist nichts was nächste Woche
nächsten Monat entschieden wird also
dass er die Illusion glauben dass da
jetzt eine der stattfindet was in drei
Wochen vorbei wäre sondern wir reden
jetzt über einen revolutionären Prozess
der kann Jahre dauern und nicht kann das
vielleicht vergleichen mit dem Kampf
gegen die Apartheid auch da gab es den
Punkt an dem sich die Welt einig war
über die politischen Lage hinweg dass
dieses Apartheid zu Regime keine Zukunft
hat und wir nähern uns in Bezug auf Iran
auch diesen Punkt und dafür sollte auch
die deutsche Bundesregierung arbeiten
damit kann man jetzt zum Schluss
vielleicht noch eine Frage die
Auswirkungen wenn der Iran eine andere
im besten Sinne demokratische Führung
bekäme wäre natürlich
enorm dazu muss man vielleicht sich
angucken welche Rolle der Iran spielt
der schickt seine Drohnen nach Russland
sorgt für Unruhe in Irak hat in Syrien
seine Finger im Spiel unterstützt die
Hisbollah im Libanon ist eine permanente
Bedrohung für Israel unterstützt die
Hoodie Rebellen im Jemen und so weiter
die geopolitische Bedeutung dieses
Landes ist also enorm glauben Sie
eigentlich vielleicht ganz kurz ist das
ein bewusst
nein es ist nicht ausreichend bewusst
weil man auch die Geschichte nicht kennt
denn wenn wir uns fragen wo denn dieses
große Chaos in unsere unmittelbaren
Nachbarregion dem Nahen Osten begonnen
hat dann war es 1979 mit der Revolution
im Iran dann der Einmarsch der Russen
Afghanistan dieser starken des
sunnitischen Extremismus Dschihadismus
als Reaktion die Kriege die Golfkriege
der Irak Irakkrieg die kriegen in die
unruhigen Syrien Libanon Palästina
Konflikte Israel all das hängt mit dem
Iran zusammen und das wäre ein
schlüsselstaat also wenn jetzt irgendwo
eine Lösung sein sollte in diesem
gewaltigen Chaos des Nahen Osten dass
uns unmittelbar betrifft und zwar nicht
nur durch Terror und Flüchtlinge sondern
in vielerlei Hinsicht dann werde Iran
des Schlüssel um überhaupt mal
irgendeine Lösung ins Auge zu fassen und
das werde eben die Bedeutung würde weit
über Iran hinausgehen sagt der
Schriftsteller Norbert kämmani vielen
herzlichen Dank nach Köln
bitte schön
und wir machen jetzt hier weiter mit den
Nachrichten und die Beginn Hannah mit
einer Tragödie es geht um Menschen auf
der Flucht ja bei einem Bootsunglück vor
der Küste Süditaliens sind mindestens 59
Migrantinnen und Migranten ums Leben
gekommen darunter auch mehrere Kinder
etwa 80 Menschen konnten sich retten
oder wurden gerettet laut Küstenwache
breite das Boot bei rauer sehen nahe der
Küste auf einen Felsen und brach
auseinander wie viele Personen genau an
Bord waren ist unklar Italiens
Innenminister piante Dosi besuchte den
Unglücksort und sprach von einer
Tragödie betonte aber zugleich dass es
notwendig sei mit Härte gegen Schlepper
und illegale Einwanderung vorzugehen
um Hilfsgüter in die vom Erdbeben
betroffenen Gebiete in Syrien zu bringen
hat die EU eine humanitäre Luftbrücke
eingerichtet im syrischen Damaskus
landeten heute die ersten zwei Flugzeuge
mit winterfesten Zelten Ausrüstung für
Unterkünfte und Heizgeräten an Bord
weitere Flüge sollen folgen die EU will
auf diesem Weg insgesamt 420 Tonnen
Hilfsgüter nach Syrien bringen etwa die
Hälfte davon aus EU eigenen
Lagerbeständen
vor gut einem Jahr hatte Bundeskanzler
Scholz ein milliardenschweres
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr
angekündigt seitdem sei die prekäre
Situation der Truppe aber keinen Deut
besser geworden erklärte der Chef des
bundeswehrverbands andre Wüstner
gegenüber dem ZDF die 100 Milliarden
Euro würden zudem nicht ausreichen und
müssten aufgestockt werden
Vertreter Israels und der Palästinenser
sind in Jordanien zusammengekommen um
über die eskalierende Gewalt in der
Region zu beraten dabei einigten sie
sich darauf die Lage durch
vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen zu
stabilisieren überschattet wurde das
Treffen von einem mutmaßlichen
palästinensischen Anschlag im
Westjordanland bei dem zwei Israelis
getötet wurden am Abend reagierten
israelische Siedler mit schweren
Ausschreitungen bereits am Mittwoch
kamen bei einem Einsatz der israelischen
Armee in naablos nach palästinensischen
Angaben mindestens 11 Palästinenser ums
Leben
vor genau einem Jahr fiel das Wort das
vieles verändert hat und noch vieles
verändern wird die zeitenwände gesagt
hat dass der Bundeskanzler und diese
Wende bringt Scholz dann dazu wie gerade
ja auch schon gezeigt sich mehr um den
globalen Süden zu kümmern aber was
bedeutet diese zeitenwände eigentlich
für uns alle Christian Sievers und
Alissa jung haben Menschen getroffen die
genau für diese Veränderung stehen quasi
exemplarisch für uns alle und zwar auch
in allen Bereichen Alltag Politik
Militär Wirtschaft und dieses Mal führt
uns die Serie Gesichter der zeitenwände
nach Norwegen die beiden haben dort
einen Mann getroffen der sein Glück kaum
fassen kann denn dank Europa sprudelt es
Geld und Öl
irgendwo da unten liegt Europas Öl und
Gas
mit dem Hubschrauber raus aufs offene
Meer eine Stunde Flug dann tauchen die
ungetümer auf die Norwegen reich gemacht
haben und gerade immer reicher machen
das Land ist in den letzten Monaten zur
mit Abstand größten Energielieferanten
der deutschen geworden ein ganzer
Kontinent steht plötzlich schlank
da drüben machen wir gerade eine neue
Erkundungsbohrung
und das da ist auch alles Umsatz
Karl Johnny herrschwick auf
inspektionstour der Vorstandschef der
größten nichtstaatlichen Öl- und
Gasfirma des Landes sagt stolz wir
halten Europa am laufen
19 Milliarden Dollar will sein Konzern
hier investieren in neue Öl und
Gasfelder Förderung rund um die Uhr
immer mehr immer effektiver
da drüben ist Schottland auf der anderen
Seite Norwegen über uns
20.000 Tonnen Stahl und hier unten
bohren Sie drei Kilometer tief
Öl und Gas in einem Labyrinth von
Leitungen diese Bohrinsel allein
produziert jeden Tag so viel um die
Tanks einer halben Millionen Autos zu
füllen für die Manager geht es schlicht
um Angebot und Nachfrage und die
Nachfrage ist enorm
wir wollen hier produzieren bis alles
leer ist das hier ist ausgelegt für eine
Produktion bis 2045
investieren wir weniger
konsumieren dann werden sie aufhören zu
bohren
[Musik]
selbst schuld also sagte ölverkäufer für
ihn ist das was er hier aus dem
Meeresboden holt vor allem ein Geschäft
wer hier draußen arbeitet verdient gut
zwei Wochen offshore vier Wochen frei
es gibt Fitnesscenter Sauna Musikraum
und vor allem reichhaltig zu essen und
doch bleibt es Leben auf einem
Pulverfass diese Uhr muss man die ganze
Zeit tragen damit man getrackt werden
kann und immer klar ist wo man gerade
ist und dann im Schrank alle haben
griffbereit so einen
Überlebensanzug fürs kalte Nordseewasser
denn sie wissen hier sollte mal etwas
schief gehen dann kann das potenziell
katastrophale Folgen haben das gesamte
System steht unter enormem Druck Gas Öl
Wasser werden hier gemeinsam aus der
Tiefe nach oben gepresst und noch auf
der Bohrinsel voneinander getrennt eine
Gaspipeline und eine für Öl führen zum
Festland jedes Leck hätte furchtbare
Konsequenzen auch für die Umwelt
die Sicherheitsregeln hier sind streng
und die Angst vor Sabotage groß viel in
Norwegen hängt ab von der Öl- und
Gasindustrie die zahlt 80% Steuern an
den Staat wenn hier die Kasse klingelt
dann geht es Norwegen gut und dennoch
wächst auch im Land selbst die Kritik an
unfassbaren gewinnen vervierfacht seit
es Krieg gibt in Europa
Norwegen ein Profiteur
vielleicht aktuell aber während Corona
haben wir viel verloren es geht halt
hoch und runter und das sind wichtig
dass der Markt immer den genauen Preis
setzt
wenn der Preis oben ist dann wollen alle
ein Rabatt wenn er unten ist dann wollen
sie ihn zahlen
Öl und Gasgeschäft irgendwann wird es
das nicht mehr geben das ist ihnen hier
klar das Wort Energiewende sagen sie
sogar auf Deutsch
aber bis dahin davon ist Karl Johnny
herrschwick überzeugt wird es noch lange
dauern bis dahin wird Europa ihn und
Norwegen brauchen aktuell mehr denn je
die afd-politikerinnen Corinna miatzka
ist mit 39 Jahren gestorben sie war
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
ihrer Partei im Bundestag und bis 2021
bayerische Landesvorsitzende miazzka sei
nach langem Kampf gegen ihre schwere
Krankheit verstorben schrieb
afd-partei-chef grupala ihre
Brustkrebserkrankung hatte mir Ende 2020
öffentlich gemacht
zum Sport zur Fußball-Bundesliga da
trafen an diesem Sonntag der SC Freiburg
und Bayer Leverkusen aufeinander die
beiden trennten sich unentschieden eins
zu eins außerdem empfingen der FC Bayern
München Union Berlin und siegte mit 3:0
bei der Nordischen Ski-WM im
slowenischen Planica konnte das deutsche
Team heute weitere Erfolge feiern mixed
Wettbewerb gewonnen die Kombinierer
Silber und bei den Skispringerinnen und
Skispringen lief es sogar noch besser
sie holten als nix Team Gold von
Norwegen
eine unbemannte Sojus-Kapsel hat
erfolgreich an der Internationalen
Raumstation ISS angedockt sie soll eine
beschädigte Raumfähre ersetzen die ein
Leck hat und im September zwei Russen
und einen Amerikaner zur Erde
zurückbringen die derzeit auf der ISS
festsitzen mitgebracht hat die Kapsel
außerdem rund 430 kg Material für die
Besatzung darunter medizinische Geräte
und Ausrüstung für wissenschaftliche
Experimente
nach dieser Woche kann ein Moment des
Durchatmens und des Innehaltens nicht
schaden oder eintauchen ins Meer
ausgeleuchtet von der Sonne die ja seit
jeher ein Magnet ist nicht nur für
Sonnenanbeter sondern auch für Künstler
und Künstlerinnen und so widmet sich nun
eine Ausstellung im Museum Barberini in
Potsdam tatsächlich sondern
Darstellungen von der Antike bis heute
es ist ein Novum dass ich Nicola
Albrecht nicht entgehen lassen wollte
dieser Einladung zu widerstehen ist nur
schwer möglich in ein Kunstwerk
eintauchen Bestandteil werden und für
den Moment die Sehnsucht nach Licht und
Wärme stillen
das war auf jeden Fall eine schöne
Überraschung dann auch mal wieder ein
bisschen Sonne zu tanken auch wenn jetzt
nicht real war aber ich fand es trotzdem
toll
ohne Sonne kein Licht ohne Licht kein
Leben es ist ihre Urkraft die hier aus
jedem werkstrahlt Mal strotzen gar
göttlicher Natur mal zart und erhellen
aber auch gefährlich für den der sich
ihr wie einst Ikarus im Übermut nähern
will
im Zentrum der Ausstellung eine
Sensation Monets impression
Sonnenaufgang eines der wertvollsten
Bilder überhaupt Namensgeber des
Impressionismus und Ikone der Moderne
zum ersten Mal in Deutschland denn
eigentlich verlässt es sein Heimatmuseum
in Paris nie
viele Besucher reisen extra zu uns nach
Paris nur um dieses Gemälde zu sehen sie
kommen aus den USA dem fernen Osten
Japan zum Beispiel und sind natürlich
unglaublich enttäuscht wenn der Monet
nicht da ist nun jetzt schicken wir sie
halt einfach mal nach Potsdam
wer nun allerdings denkt der Rest sei
nur schmückendes Beiwerk irrt Rubens
nimmt uns mit im Sonnenwagen des Apollon
Caspar David Friedrich lockt uns in
seine gefühlvollen Landschaften
[Musik]
und diese Sonne erschien pünktlich zur
Eröffnung sogar über die Museum
heute morgen als die Sonne noch in einem
Dunst aber schon als weiße Scheibe zu
sehen war musste ich an das Bild von
William Turner denken dass ein solchen
Morgendunst zeigt es ist ein wilder Ritt
durch
2500 Jahre Kunst und
Menschheitsgeschichte der inspiriert und
gerade jetzt so gut tut
ich finde es bedrückt einen wirklich
ständig die Nachricht und das kann man
einfach der positive Energie freien Lauf
lassen viele Sachen sind deprimieren
gerade und da ist das natürlich ein
wunderbarer Blick in einer eine Zukunft
die leuchtet und wer am Ende von ihrer
Macht und Strahlkraft noch nicht
überzeugt ist sollte sie im Video
zusammengesetzt aus 200.000 Aufnahmen
eines NASA Satelliten betrachten die
Sonne als Kraftwerk deren Feuerstürme
mit etwas Fantasie sogar ein Lächeln
produzieren
[Musik]
Kraftwerk finde ich ganz not was hier
nächste Woche wichtig wird ein kurzer
Ausblick
[Musik]
am Montag jetzt sich der Brand des
Reichstags zum 90 Mal bis heute nicht
vollständig aufgeklärt nutzten die
Nationalsozialisten den Anschlag um ihre
Repressionen zu verschärfen
am Mittwoch werden die Gas und die
strompreisbremse in Kraft treten die
Kilowattstunde Gas kostet dann höchstens
12 Cent beim Strom sind es maximal 40
Cent garantiert jeweils für 80% des
Verbrauchs
ab Mittwoch wird Außenministerin
baerbock auf dem G20-Treffen in Indien
zu Gast sein bärbock trifft dort
möglicherweise auch ihren russischen
Amtskollegen lavrov
der Bundeskanzler ist ebenfalls auf
Reisen am Freitag wird er von
US-Präsident beiden in Washington
empfangen
am Sonntag wird in Peking der
chinesische Volkskongress beginnen zum
Auftakt wird der scheidende Premier
League in seinem Rechenschaftsbericht
das Wachstumsziel für dieses Jahr
vorgeben
[Musik]
fehlt noch der Blick aufs Wetter morgen
gibt es einige Schneeschauer in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen und am
Alpenrand sonst scheint oft die Sonne
die Temperaturen erreichen -1 bis plus 8
Grad dabei weht der windteils durch aus
östlichen Richtungen in den nächsten
Tagen zeigt sich auf die Sonne bei
Temperaturen zwischen ein und 12 Grad
also Sonne am Himmel oder aber auch in
Potsdam in der Ausstellung ja das war es
von uns wir wünschen noch einen schönen
Abend machen sie es gut wo auch immer
sie sind tschüss
[Musik]